do these guys look like that you're
coming across can you sort of describe
you know what you're seeing a lot
of I mean it's hard because like on
Tinder you're kind of like picking what
guys you want to match with so you're
really only picking guys that are like
your type um
so the the looks are there for the most
part um but it's really just like the
personality isn't
there
personalities lacking like yes Talking
Dead Fish here or like um for
instance I'm a Scorpio so I'm like super
sassy hard-headed
those qualities and there's not a lot of
guys that can handle that um sometimes I
you think guys hear when women
say I'm difficult to handle or they
can't handle
that how do you think that's interpreted
by those high quality guys that you're
looking for I don't know they're
probably
mad mad mad how like what do you mean
like they're probably salty about it I
guess I don't
know salty about a gal that they can't
handle about the way that I said that
yes okay so why say it then if it
doesn't get you a positive
response I mean I don't say that to them
but I'm just giving like an example but
does your demeanor does your bio does
your conversation does everything sort
of leading out of that signal that
that's who you are I mean you mentioned
bossom right that's something else I
made a note on
like that's a vibe that you're giving
off
right yes do you think guys like boss
girls
successful competent guys putting a dent
universe that have a strong muscular
physique over 5
foot6 I think guys that are comfortable
with themselves
do so if they're not comfortable with
themselves then they'll have a problem
with it probably
so okay
interesting um let me just throw this uh
Super Chat up real quick because I
always try to acknowledge Him He says
Rachel how are you going to run a
dealership if you only know service tech
uh can you be a top salesperson for the
year if not you have no business running
a dealership what's your thought on
that um I think I said this before but I
have still a long way to go um I've been
in the dealership business for 10 years
since I was
18 um started off as a receptionist
worked my way up um
I have never sold cars would I ever sell
cars probably not because it's just not
me
um but I think there is I think that his
point is that the whole point of a car
dealership is to move cars and if you
are not experienced in moving cars how
can you run a car dealership moving
cars there's plenty of people that run
car dealerships without selling cars if
that's what he's asking but they would
have had some experience in moving cars
cuz that's the whole point of the
dealership to get cars off the
lot not
necessarily what's the point of a
dealership if it's not to get cars off
the
lot
uh I feel like this is a trick question
um
[Music]
um I don't think there's like a point to
a
dealership I think that there are
so
many different things that are involved
in a
dealership okay I mean servicing cars is
one component of it do they make more
money off servicing cars or selling
cars it depends where you go some
places it's also different every month
when we review our numbers but um there
are
different um places where the service
department outnumbers the sales
department every single month
out all the time um but there's also
months where the sales department kicks
our butt and they're doing really well
so I think it depends on your numbers I
mean all of that you know is in manager
meetings every month do you ever get hit
on while you're at work I mean
infiniti's it's more of a luxury brand I
mean it's an upscale brand anyway it's
above Nissan so um there's like there's
got to be some people walking in and out
there there's got to be some guys
walking in and out there that that drive
a upscale brand that can afford an
upscale brand you ever get head on by
any of these
guys
yes is it ever worth going out with with
any of
them
no they pretty much because I don't
really mess with like business and
pleasure just because I want to keep it
professional um so that way in case
said if it was a
customer I they may need something from
me in the future and I want to make sure
that they come back to me
okay all right
um I want to go back to the bossom thing
and your like goals in relationships
like you were engaged to get married it
sounds like marriage was important to
you and having a serious relationship is
important to you what does that lead to
is it is it is it a family is it kids
like
yeah so I want to um I want to have a a
good I want to have an even number of
kids I wanted to have four kids that was
my plan okay so you need to find a guy
that's that's able to bring home the
bacon while you're taking care of four
babies I mean I'd still love to work
while
I'm taking care of kids I don't expect
13 hour
days probably not
um but I don't expect the man that I'm
with to do all of the work or
to think that I'm just gonna sit home
and take care of kids I don't I don't
want to do that I want to still be able
to work and take care of kids I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clip's
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out